ah
okay
uh hello and welcome to our career
master class is an mba enough to be a
business leader today the ideal profile
of a digital business leader in 2021
our speaker today is professor jagdish
sheth who is the charles h kelstadt
professor of business at emory
university
i'm stewart creek i'm in the marketing
department here at simply learn and
before we get started
a quick note on how to operate the webex
controls for those of you on webex
please enter your questions for
professor sheth
on the q a function q
a box we will log those together and
have
uh give those to him at the end of the
presentation in our q a
session and then if you do have
chat messages for us make sure you
address those
to all panelists so that we all see them
if you are on the
live streams with youtube live or
linkedin live when we come up with
polls we will let you put the
answers into the chat box this is our
first
poll and we'll do another one at the end
of the presentation
and this poll asks
your level of experience and how you are
doing today
so if you would take about half a minute
and let us know how much experience you
currently have
and then we'd like to ask how you're
feeling today we've been asking this
since the start of the pandemic
to see how people are coping
and just about 15 seconds more we'll
give you
and we'll close the poll in five four
3 2
1.
so as you can see we have a seasoned
audience here um
40 of the respondents have 10 or more
years of experience
um and
we also thankfully have
most people saying that they're doing
well today
um for those of you who are not feeling
so well hopefully this presentation
will give you useful information that
will um help
brighten your mood so with
with that i am going to uh
introduce uh professor jagdish sheth
the charles h kellstep professor of
business at emory university
um he's a renowned scholar he's an
internationally recognized thought
leader he's published
over 300 research papers over 30 books
he's the 2020 padma busan award
recipient
from the government of india and
um he's a noted
expert in modern business trends and
how to be a business leader
and welcome professor i'm going to stop
sharing the slides
and we'll just have a conversation thank
you so much to it
um so thank you for being here this
morning uh
professor this morning here we where we
are in north america
um we have a lot of folks who are in our
indian audience
and as i noted we have a fairly seasoned
group
um so these people are very curious
about
how things have changed from the
traditional world
where the mba used to be the ticket to
business leadership and
your thesis is that this is not the case
today
um can you tell us about how you view
that
yeah i think the mba
was designed primarily for the
industrial age
it really was introduced right after
world war ii
primarily for engineers to learn
internal vocabulary and the language of
business
as they join a company hoping that from
engineering
they will rise to management level that
was the whole intent
yeah so they had to learn
typical things like double entry systems
macroeconomics microeconomics behavioral
sciences
it is no longer the case today there's a
huge change
uh first of all we are in the digital
age
so all the processes and the procedures
established were on a manual basis at
one time
and today everything is computerized to
a level where you can't work
without access to the computer and the
network and the databases clearly one so
that's
that's one main factor the other reason
is that
events are taking place today outside
the control of the company
and mba was never designed for
externalities
plan b in some fashion and i'll give you
two
i will give you two quick examples our
first one is
more man-made which was the great
recession
of 2008 and nine with all of the
restructuring of the you know uh housing
market
leveraging it to a level the whole
economy collapsed
its impact on business was massive
not just on the down of the stock price
for example
but it was a lot greater than that
liquidity became an issue
and how do you manage your corporation
people with cash flow begin to buy out
others just went
on and on and of course more currently
it is the impact of pandemic nobody
imagine
that a natural disaster first of all
will last this long
unlike an earthquake or a flood or
something
and will have such a persistent change
so i think that is very key
so we have to revise the mba because
more external factors are driving the
industry and the company
uh such as the supply chain disruption
for example
it's not really more so we have to
understand that there's clearly one
major factor
it was designed for internal
communication internal coordination
how do we relate to the external
ecosystem and the environment
is becoming very key and i'll just give
you a couple of examples to it you know
at one time the typical ceo for javo
used to be primarily
you were a accounting guy he had a
controller
you are a treasurer he became the cpa
cfo
mostly managing internal capital but
today's cfo has to be
very good at mergers and acquisitions
how do you negotiate between two
companies is
far greater different skill set that is
true for hr function
it is no longer compliance and
procedures it is saying how do i recruit
talent for the next generation
every major function today at the top
level like a vp of manufacturing
hr function finance have a next plateau
of understanding
which the current mba does not offer so
that's one factor
industrial age to the digital age or
what i call the world go is going from
physical first to digital first
everything we are doing
is digital first right yeah my
my second reason is very different
this mba was designed for general
managers
in other words how quickly you are a
typical iit
graduate in india top engineering
college
you join iim top management college
you start at the lower level but you are
ramped up very quickly to become a brand
manager
a business unit manager and you rise to
the top
in your early 40s late 30s
today that is not the case today
surprisingly what
people are looking for in the mba
program is specialized mba
so you have to be a generalist we
understand but are you also
very much in depth so what i call a
deep generalist how are you expert in
that field so
just give you another example 40 percent
of all the budget today is going
for digital conversion into the
marketing function
it is no longer the cio traditionally
which is morally downsizing outsizing
putting things on the cloud computing
etc etc
but 40 percent of the i.t budget is
going for the marketing
discipline which is changing
dramatically from paper and pencil
to television to now obviously
everything
digital advertising digital
communication and the chief marketing
officer
has no idea about digital marketing
so that's the second major factor so you
have to have more depth
in your discipline today than ever
before
and a third factor is the one that i
know is your passion also
namely that half-life of knowledge is
getting
shorter and shorter in software it is
down to
18 months in management it is also down
to 18 months
so by the time you graduate in a typical
mba
whether it is more advanced than me
after working a few years
half of the knowledge is obsolete
or its useful life is gone so the
concepts that we studied in the old days
about time and motion studies
concepts like we studied about you know
managing the
cueing system for example in in
stochastic processes and
you know just in time inventory
now today we have to learn more about
blockchain
better learn more about distributed
manufacturing
we have to learn about you know how to
coordinate smaller
quantities you made in all different
locations and at the same time you have
an uninterrupted supply chain
so half-life of knowledge is getting
shorter and shorter
that means by definition mba is no
longer a terminal degree
you have to start thinking about
lifelong learning
how do you go into lifelong learning
while you are on the job
becomes very important so that's the
second third message that comes about
about why the current mba to generate
leadership
is not as useful as it used to be
yeah and i i take your point about the
nba being a product
of the second world war
in the post-war environment one of the
things that
uh happened in the second world war was
the rise of scientific uh management in
production
with people like geran and
peter drucker and that type of thing and
that that became the template for
management for
for many years and it's great for a
world where
products don't change very quickly and
you can manufacture manufacturing large
runs
and then of course the japanese
manufacturing revolution people
right started learning how to be more
adaptive but today
as you said a lot of products don't have
a physical form
they're essentially digital products or
services
and we live in a world now where
product updates can happen many times a
day if you look at
a product like facebook or that type of
thing
where not only do the updates happen
many times a day but you don't even
know they're happening until you see the
presence of a new button or
your function operates a little bit
differently than it did yesterday
and so we live in a very
different world when you look at
one of the trends in business today um
we hear much more and have been hearing
much more about
stakeholders than shareholders and
so how how is the
the notion of business as
an enterprise to make profit for
shareholders
transformed into business
as uh serving a range of stakeholders
in a business of business has always
been
more than business to look at the
history of industrial revolution
in england and in germany if you go back
to the cities which are
bigger cities now like birmingham for
example
in england or if you go to newcastle for
example
those were locations blessed with rivers
waterways or some natural resource like
iron ore or whatever it is
wealthy families began to settle there
to go from the agriculture to the
industrial age
and they lived in those small towns
the towns and i and invited them gave
them the natural resources
access public resources in many ways and
there was a very good symbiotic
relationship like two peas in a pod
if their family remain in that small
town they always were stakeholder
oriented because every sunday
you went to church and church was a
great equalizer
you are not above god was a clear
message about the community
and you understood that message your
neighbors actually were your managers or
your managers or your neighbors
your children went to the same school or
grandchildren if you are older
as your managers children so you had a
lot of informal social communication
outside of the corporate hierarchy there
was only one school typically in that
town
this is how the families were always
wealthy families
were always stakeholder oriented
they were interested in suppliers who
came to offer their services
because you were based in there it'll be
almost like bentonville arkansas today
for walmart
right scanner excanatity for a general
electric
r mark for ibm which all moved away from
the small town
mentality to go for the bigger city
and once you listed your stocks on the
public market
you had to relocate to the capital
markets
so the family members began to say
older generation can stay here but we
will move away
toward the capital markets like new york
london hong kong wherever they are
or bombay in india for example away from
the roots
and therefore now you are preoccupied
with only one stakeholder
out of the five stakeholders you forget
the community where you made the money
where your factories are you don't live
in that factory town
you forget your suppliers and their
loyalty and their value what you can
create
forget the employees and even forget the
customer surprisingly
you become shareholder obsessed i think
this divorce of the family
away from the place of where you do the
work
to the place where you live and go to
the capital markets i think it went out
of
end after the first energy crisis in the
70s
as you know we had a probably major
restructuring which we haven't talked
about
as much as the great depression but
private equity took hold of the
companies
stock market collapsed after the energy
crisis you were a conglomerate large
conglomerate
and therefore the value was very good
your stock price was down
your debt capital went up your debt to
equity ratio we created junk bonds
to survive the companies and
surprisingly in the process
private equity companies whether it's a
warren buffett's you know company or kkr
which was a more
hostile takeover would buy out the
company by investing
and break them into pieces so obsession
towards shareholder value became
much stronger in the early 80s and
lasted till about recently
today now we are back to the same notion
that
business as an institution has a purpose
in life
other than making money that was the
wrong paradigm
it never was there but it was imposed
because the necronic necessities
like in the 80s we did outsizing
downsizing right sizing
outsourcing we did everything only to
survive for the shareholder
and i think that notion is going is
becoming so today we have an idea
that actually it is in your
self-interest
that to be stakeholder oriented because
doing well by doing good gives you more
financial returns
and i have a book out by my colleague
raj
sodia and myself or maybe 15 years ago
we wrote it called
forms of endearment where we showed
companies that were employee oriented
customer oriented community oriented
uh and and you know and and and and
supplier oriented actually financially
performed better
than the companies that were strictly
shareholder oriented which is the book
called
good to great look at that thing
good to great the new paradigm is great
to gone
so all the great companies who are
several driven i mean the icon was
generally electric
we placed jack worth so well but it's
gone now
it's fascinating to watch yeah it's it's
interesting
the two two of the trends you mentioned
one is a
financial engineering because i recall
during the
the 1980s and even before that we had
the rise of junk bonds which was
you know taking a look at companies
simply from their financial perspective
and saying
well we can sell high interest high
interest
bonds to help these companies
reach the financial markets but
that led to restructurings that
completely decimated
you know old brand companies and and the
the um let's see if i can remember
what i was about to say about the the
other trend
yeah it'll it'll come back to me i'm
sorry
oh yeah i'm sorry great to good um
good to great great to gone i
i remember the era of um
in pursuit of excellence where we had
companies like gm and
general electric and 3m and these
wonderful brands held up as
the perfect examples of how to manage
and
um like dinosaurs that
tended to go by the wayside if they
haven't
completely reinvented themselves they're
not here anymore or they're not
totally significant anymore so
absolutely i have a book on that one
actually again came out in 2007
i originally had the title the question
was
is the most insightful question i've
been ever asked by chairman of a large
company
when you are a one-on-one advisor like a
coach
in one of the luncheon meetings just
one-on-one
he raised a question why good companies
fail
and i never thought good companies fail
the institutions never fail
they're immortal humans are mortal i
said i have no answer but i will do all
the research and came out with a book
called the seven bad habits of good
companies
or self-destructive habits of good
companies and the underlying punch line
was from all the research
the good companies fail when they're
either unable
or unwilling to change when the external
ecosystem has changed dramatically
technology globalization competition
whatever the paradigm is or rules
regulation or policy change
so unwillingness is very interestingly
so here is a company called digital
world class by the way
i mean they really competed well with
ibm who is a monopoly
yes but the founder ken olsen never
believed
that the pc can do the work of a
mainframe computer he thought pc was a
toy
he was an mit brilliant scientist and he
destroyed the company on his way out
i've never seen
a founder destroying the company in 25
years
after ramping up so well because he had
a belief system
that he never believed in this
technology power as we see today
cell phone today in fact the same way
let me take a little example here stuart
today's automobile and i worked in the
auto industry for all major companies
it was primarily electromechanical thing
today an automobile
is not metal bending but it is a
software
and basically what i would call chips
and software okay
to me a tesla is nothing more than
nothing less than
a very large and mobile smartphone
it's just like a smartphone
that's a very good way of looking at it
that's very accurate metaphor for that
yeah so technology has transformed the
water industry
of course from the gasoline engine we
are now going to our electric engine
these things are already happening
so the best of the companies unless they
are able to change cannot change
i cannot survive one of the best one of
the
bad habits in my seven and bad habits
is denial of new realities i saw that in
the 70s in the auto industry where
there were laughter japanese car makers
small you know
datsun 210 honda civic
you know toyota corolla small cars they
said these guys are fine
they will maybe reminisce and its
players they will never compete but
today if you look at the global rule of
three
of automobiles volkswagen is number one
toyota follows number two
gm ford or distant third fourth and
there is no
guarantee that both can even survive
there's a huge consolidation that is
about to take place
in the auto industry with two key
transforming changes
one of course is the battery to an
electric cars and the other one is tesla
like cars
which is basically a software driven
mechanical product essentially and so
and then when market is shifted it's no
longer america the largest market
the market is all china now so chinese
policy will make more difference
about the auto industry than the
american policy or even the european
union policy
just as an example yeah and
um to your point about
automobiles as being software and ships
one of the big issues
in the u.s recovery now
is the inability of automobile companies
to be to be able to access chips the
global
supply chain having been changed and
disrupted
they can't get the chips that go into
the cars
and unlike years past you can't just go
to a foundry and say here's the
specifications make this part
right so even when president biden
says we're going to bring chip
manufacturing back to the united states
that's you know a problem that's tens of
billions of dollars and
several years to solve rather than you
know simple
let's let's roll up our sleeves and get
it done
um and it reflects the idea that
companies didn't look forward and say
well the nature of our product has
changed and now we don't
you know need to worry about whether we
are near a source of steel
and coke we need to be worried about
whether we have adequate supply
to silicon and
fabricated chips so it's it's a it's
quite an interesting
uh difference what was the name of the
second book that you mentioned by the
way
yeah it's called the self-destructive
habits of good companies and it was just
reprinted in india with updates
by pearson i think it was released in
month of april
or may somewhere around that time
it's worth reading because it really
shows you
how companies destroy themselves
not competition destroying them or a
population ecology with that means
primarily life and birth and death kind
of a notion
inevitability of dying because you were
born this is a very different theory
it is already translated in 14 languages
that i know of
for example it struck a chord came out
just before 2008-2009 economic recession
or a great recession as we call it and
the book is even more relevant today
because think about the whole change in
technology
today in among the all industries i've
analyzed
there's always one large company among
the top three companies
is from an emerging market so there are
many industries where
mexico dominates one of the companies
like grupo bimbo
in flower or all-purpose flour for
example
uh a cmx in a cement company for example
brazilian companies that dominate the
world all the beer industry is
concentrated by the brazilians
essentially for example
brazilian companies have bought at times
through private equity
in india you have the uh you know i did
the builder group which is the largest
carbon
or black carbon you know
it is probably the second largest in
aluminum sheet aluminum for example
you see every place a chinese
corporation among the top ones
lenovo in pc business competing with hp
and
obviously dale or acer whatever they are
you see higher in appliances
only one company is left in america
whirlpool we already have ge gone
because hire bought them out
it's interesting to watch and of course
in all the digital products you see
alibaba over the world
just goes on and on so japanese are very
big and i mean chinese are very big in
steel industry
very big in raw materials
pharmaceuticals
so one of the three global players is
not all
western countries advanced economies
there are quite a few asian companies
rising
which we have to watch as a trend
yep it's um
it's a very different world from
yeah the post-world war era where
all of the world's economies except the
us were
devastated by the war and
now companies you know countries that we
didn't
think of as industrial powerhouses have
basically taken over um under the radar
so to speak
we have a question about um
if an mba is not the path of digital
leadership that it once
was what is
that's a very good question actually uh
there is no one single path that's the
first point we have to make
a greater degree of specialization
in a given function is important however
you do it so you may take a specialized
mba
in finance or specialized mba in
marketing or
branding or whatever it is it's getting
more and more specialized
but most importantly i would strictly
say
it's lifelong learning so online
learning is becoming going to become a
part of your
routine part of the job part of the
activities that you must to take time
out
to constantly learn from either you know
platforms like
you know simply learn for example or
counterparts but
more importantly really learning from
every media available
today social media generates so much of
content
uh i find youtube very useful
surprisingly
that's nearly one factor second one
related to the mba program is that we
taught there
how no why we give them
theories we give them explanations
frameworks
today you have to also know know how
not just know why which means how to is
very important at the same time
so today's mba now is all about
experiential learning
doing is as much immersive learning as
opposed to just cognitive learning as we
call it
so that is very key as a change but
basically
nursing will be lifelong learning in
other words don't go for the degree
itself
but any certification in a specialized
area let's say i want to study
blockchain
blockchain is a foundation for bitcoins
but it is the foundation for all of the
supply chain transactions all four major
accounting firms have blessed blockchain
as an alternative to double entry system
we do it through paper and pencil
or quickbooks or something like that i
think it's a massive change so
so learning those specialized skill sets
as modules is more than necessary
as opposed to a whole degree for example
and this of course applies to people who
have already obtained the degrees yes
it's necessary to continue to study
the modular skills
and um as as you said you know the cmo
may not understand the digital marketing
principles
but if if he or she is wise
uh the cmo will study digital marketing
um and learn the principles at least to
the level where they can
um track manage the work of
the people who do it so just to just
just to just to amplify that
the biggest outsourcing function i found
is not the it services which you all
know quite a lot
and i was on the board of repro so i
understand outsourcing business and i.t
services
it is no longer in fact surprisingly hr
which was outsourced quite a lot
and automated but the largest
outsourcing today
of the dollars that company spends is
marketing
marketing is basically coordinating
suppliers
and we never teach in marketing courses
how do you select the vendors for
example
how do you evaluate the vendors when you
buy so much
you buy market research from outside for
example
you have the distribution channels that
you have to manage which is outside
yeah you have to manage in fact
advertising through ad agencies
so you need to learn you cannot be a
good buyer
or a sophisticated buyer unless you know
the knowledge
how to evaluate a group of vendors or
suppliers
or partners whoever they are i was very
surprised when i found that
marketing is the most outsourced
function and we never teach
vendor management in marketing for
example let me give one more example
you know in the old physical days you
made the product
add the value add to manufacturing you
store the product brought it to the
store
and waited for the customers today in
digital first
you are starting with order entry first
so marketing is becoming more and more
supply chain management
is it possible for marketing online
platform
or even a salesperson talking on the
phone to know in a real time
where is the inventory how can you
deliver what is the price point
and the buyer typically no one wants to
know how much can i buy
and when will you deliver that at one
time sales guys had no idea they would
throw the paper over on the other side
to the
operations or manufacturing people but
today it is seamless
so i know right now when i go online to
say
is the product available right now is it
in the stock
if it's a multi-branch retailer they
will say it is not in the stock in this
branch
or this retail location but some other i
mean it's mind-boggling change
so marketing is transforming into more
like a supply chain management
so this kind of a convergence by
functions is something else we need to
understand also
which primarily says that there is no
some such thing
as one degree mba that will be solution
for everything
you have to you have to learn again and
again and again lifelong learning is my
main message
a very important message um
one of the things that that you've
written about and spoken about is
um the nature of leadership
yes and one thing you say is that a key
ingredient of leadership that is missing
in a lot of cases is empathy
could you could you expand on that
yeah ultimately there are three things
every leader should have competence
which is the expertise of the function
or the geography or the product that you
are responsible for
the other one is passion if you don't
have a passion
in the management job leadership job
it's a burnout
it will burn out so quickly so passion
is what drives
not compensation is conclusive evidence
we are finding it
but the third element and probably
equally important as passion
is empathy are you compassionate with
the other side
that you are managing are you
compassionate
toward the nature are you compassionate
toward the physical environment
compassionate about people
and we are finding that empathy is the
missing dimension more so
than competency and passion
in the tripod relationship three legs of
a stool
you need to be a good leader empathy
needs to be emphasized a lot more
people are even oblivious of the kinds
of struggles their own employees are
going through in their personal lives
and people are simply saying i'm a
manager i need demand the work to do it
and here is the way you have to deliver
no matter what i think we don't
by the way one element of empathy is
listening skills
and listening skill does not mean
somebody has to say
something is the body language right you
can hear the listening skill
very quickly as you walk into the
classroom for example we know
if the class is energized today or not
it's all about learning listening skills
and great teachers are the same way
they're subject matter experts
they have a great empathy with the class
they teach and of course they're very
passionate in the subject matter
it goes beyond salary and the
compensation so
so it's the same thing about leadership
but what's missing is empathy
would you re repeat for the audience the
three legs of the leadership stool
yeah the three legs are competence
or what we call expertise
second one is empathy
third one is enthusiasm or passion
for passion empathy competence
would be the three and by the way this
is very important
a good leader has to have all three
there is no
trade-off between one or the other your
greater passion does not mean you cannot
be empathetic also at the same time
and in our evaluation of startup people
that hr practices
we only measure people's competency we
do not measure whether people are
empathetic or not
or people have a passion or not so we
are adding now
because ultimately most what matters
most in
any company is the selection process
not the training and the development
selection is the most
important criterion who do you select as
a employee
who do you select as a manager who do
you select as
executive etc is very key and that part
of the hr function
we need to upgrade to going beyond just
measuring competency
or expertise or subject matter experts
and that's an important point because if
you select
the correct people people with the the
who share your passion who show empathy
and who are confident at what they do
you can
cultivate them with ongoing
education training coaching
to make them into both uh better
technical employees but also better
leaders
yeah a corporation
is i'm sorry
corporation is like a good diamond
cutter
if you have a rough diamond corporation
knows how to polish the diamond and get
more brilliance out
but you cannot create a brilliant
diamond out of coal
you've got to have a rough diamond so
you recruit a person
who is a rough diamond you know and
through mentorship and leadership you
will polish and get brilliance out
which also says that they change there's
a role change of the manager
manager the word boss is becoming
negative now
especially with the younger talent they
hate the word boss it's like a four
letter word in their mind
not only about the young men yeah i i i
can point out that
that um in some cases
the word boss refers to the
villain in a video game and the other
the the common uh the common um
you know phrases you know the big boss
is the is the
the final villain at the last level of
the video game that you
and the one you have to defeat so yeah i
understand that
bosses is not a good word for for
a lot of young people and back to that
empathy dimension
i think best way is to immerse yourself
in those situations
you suddenly come to realize a sense of
gratitude
how much better you are a sense of
therefore giving back to the society
so nowadays many corporations especially
in india
are now recommending that the executives
and managers
take a time out one week vacation time
paid even
and go back to the villages where your
forefathers came from small villages
from which
they rose quite well and sell the
community there for a week
because once you immerse into that if
you know the
poorer of the society the disadvantage
to the society
the greater the empathy you will gain in
the process greater you will have an
understanding
of how blessed you are rather than
thinking about
more and more and more you say about how
do i contribute more to the society
it's becoming very important message now
especially for
leaders of corporations to understand
empathy
to understand that their role is more
than just
making money for themselves or for their
shareholders
there's an expression roots and wings
which talks about the
the skills and capabilities that you've
developed in life are the wings that
will carry you forward but
right you always have to remember the
roots of where you came from and
where you got not only those skills but
the values behind them
and yeah that's an important
thing um i think we
can move to the questions and answers um
but before we
wanted to ask if you had any other
topic that you wanted to just cover
before we did that
uh there's only one area that i would
strongly recommend
we all think through i think the
sustainability environmental
sustainability
is a very serious challenge
i don't think governments can solve it
i think industry or the business has an
equal
obligation and an interest to be
sustainable themselves
environmentally not just financially
climate change is real i've done a lot
of research
and ultimately it says that most of the
problem as you saw yesterday's news
alone
the co2 has increased by 50 percent
from the industrial age before the
industrial age and after the industrial
age
that's the last hundred years very
importantly
biggest reason why we have the climate
change problem is that
in the agricultural age we had the
production and the consumption in the
same place
and about the same time like 24 hours 48
hours because
we had no refrigeration you could not
store it
once we divorced production from
consumption
and we went into mass production
thinking scale is important
so you produce so much in one place now
you have to ship it out to some other
market
for it to be sold for it to be consumed
which creates a carbon footprint in my
research i find carbon footprint is not
done
as much by factories as people think or
by the transport as people think
but by the home especially american
homes
is nothing but made out of chemicals
sightings are out of chemicals my dry
walls are our chemicals
they emit a lot of carbon footprint
surprisingly just sitting there
and of course refrigeration at home
generates enormous carbon footprint
the automobile which is a part of the
home market as i call it
the use of the automobile creates carbon
footprint and of course the next place
for carbon footprint turns out to be
supermarkets and as we more and more
industrialized
modernize our retailing you see
supermarkets having nothing but chains
of refrigerators
or freezing freezers that's putting
enormous pressure
each one counts very little but
collectively it becomes a very large
footprint
in fact most of the research shows you
that 70
or more carbon footprint air pollution
water wastage all comes from the home
which is ultimately what can
consumers do or what can the public
policy
and the industry cooperatively motivate
the consumers
to be more mindful mindful consumption
is becoming
so the central reason why we may
change the climate back again go back to
the old ways today
mass customization the toyota processors
for example in manufacturing
i can make cost efficient production in
smaller factories as much
as i could do in big factories i don't
need that scale advantage because i know
how to produce in a lean operations way
so one can have small distributed
factories
very easily production is made only for
consumption in that market
not as much warehousing storage etc i'm
giving you a long lecture there's a
whole presentation
but i do want to mention that please be
aware
about sustainability becoming main
important issue at the board level
one of the risk management which is what
the board is responsible for
is now asking everything about climate
change how are we doing in terms of
carbon neutral or zero carbon
and that's why you see today there's a
much more pressure by the capitalist
people who invest in your companies are
demanding that and of course in
india we have passed a law which says it
has to be in your
financial statements annual reports not
only financial well-being
but sustainability well-being or csr as
they call it
is very key that actually leads into
our q a very well because one of the
questions
uh from rebecca is how important do you
think
an understanding of the un
sustainability goals
will be for managers and leaders in the
near and distant future
yeah among the long list of things
they've articulated
17 major goals there such as poverty
reduction etc
but ultimately it culminates into three
major things
profit people planet
and i think so long as triple bottom
line as it is called
replacing the old thinking of only
profit as the only motive
of a corporation so that is additional
thing that we need to learn
how to teach in colleges we never talk
about triple bottom line
as the obligation or the opportunity for
corporations
so it is very important the
united nations new millennium goals
with which countries align public policy
and the corporations also align in the
same direction
um we have a youtube live viewer
named mosman who wants to know what are
a few things you would recommend to
young leaders
in their 20s to focus on
in order to grow and become
sought after and respected leaders in
their own right
two or three things first very quickly
realize that there is no some such thing
as your
personal life and a professional life
that you can have personal life behavior
in a one way and a professional in a
different way today
everything you do is monitored stored by
the media
of cameras etc there is no gated
community behind which you can hide
which means at this age make sure that
you have
all preventive measures
don't say things that are not
appropriate don't do things that are not
appropriate
it'll be discovered even 30 years from
now as it is done recently as you know
by many of the leaders paying the price
of some misbehavior in their early days
you are young so make sure that your
code of conduct
is driven by your own inner character
which is transparent and equally
appropriate for family behavior as it is
appropriate for professional
uh corporate behavior there is no some
such thing as separating the two anymore
in fact jokingly i say but semi
seriously
if i want to know what i did yesterday i
do a google search on me
and i find i did things that i didn't
even know
yeah it's all recorded especially when
you use
media i mean smartphones in social media
it's all there i'm amazed how much
information is already gathered
on all of us so that's one key message
second message is to
do things that is of passion
do not make a trade-off between economic
livelihood
and a passionate livelihood
otherwise you will have mid-life crisis
in your early 30s
10 years from now if you're in your 20s
please keep that in the back of your
mind
i am 82 years old i had an 80th birthday
two years ago
and i got up and i say today's 80 is the
new 60.
today 60 is the new 40 and today's 40 is
all mid-life crisis
because we never converged our passion
with our livelihoods that's the second
major
message that would work for companies
or work for individuals bosses or
leaders
where you know your passion is taken out
by the boss boss is more like a mentor
more getting enabling you to succeed
rather than him to succeed
through you kind of a notion that's a
very important message
and the third message for the young
people is that think about giving
back now don't think about giving back
only begins when you retire
giving back does not mean money it is
time and talent and all of you are very
good talented people
how can you give back to the society in
any way in your neighborhood for example
family related issues community wise or
a national level
it is very important because it will
give you an inner happiness
so you can cope with the world in a much
better way
today the world is unfortunately so fast
moving so fast changing
with social media everywhere out there
in fact the largest single nation is no
longer india or china
1.3 1.4 billion but but what i call a
facebook nation
with 2 billion citizens
all over the world and there's a
whatsapp nation
there's a youtube nation it's
fascinating
you are constantly going to be
influenced by them
so to learn how to select properly which
medium you will patronize what kinds of
things you will watch etc
but giving back somehow would be very
important because it will give you
an inner anchor and inner satisfaction
and it can be done through the
corporation
it can be done in the corporation it can
be done in the community
where you grew up for example especially
in india this is much more important
and fortunately that is the ethos of
indian
population indians are trained always to
say
a money is not that critical it's the
knowledge that's very important
and the last message which is a fourth
element although i like to stick with
three
is that uh there's a very good saying in
the eastern cultures
when the student is ready the teacher
will show up
very important which says that be a
learner
have the aptitude to say i don't know
anything how can i learn more and more
and who will teach you is not as
somebody who is a guru
or an expert but your peers can teach
you
your boss can teach you your nature can
teach you the mountain can teach you
the garden can teach you if you have the
learning skills or listening skills so
aptitude to learn
is the one that will drive you
positively in the society
you are not just a good human being but
you have to become good citizen
of a world or a nation by and large
that's the advice i would give to
younger people
okay um i'm looking through the
questions
what uh ashma
asks what do you think in your opinion
will come after digital marketing and
there's
another question related from another
learner um
ravi raj um do you think the digital age
is here to stay
or is there something that will come
after the digital they era
see one consequence of the digital age
itself
is that it's going to make us much more
individualistic it allows us the freedom
to behave each one of our own way pretty
much
i mean i have said basically that today
with smartphones
every family is becoming a roommate
family
you see if a typical family we all rush
for dinner
we have no time to eat together dinner
is a chore how quickly we do it and
immediately
each one of us goes in our own corner or
our own room if we are blessed to have
more
of bedrooms etc somebody's on youtube
somebody's text messaging somebody's
watching tv somebody's talking
so we live like a roommate family
the more you become individualistic
surprisingly
the more you are influenced by your
inner self so we go through the stage
from
in the digital age to have digital
avatars of our own
where artificial becomes more real and
more meaningful
but the stage behind that one
surprisingly is
the antidote of too much digital
addiction etc
turns out to be spirituality so we will
see the age of spirituality rising
as we have more and more diffusion of
digital technology
over everybody universal universal
internet access
smartphones will be so cheap everybody
can carry it's just like paper and
pencil in the old days of literacy
you know 100 200 years ago where they
became very important
to have knowledge writing storing memory
i think is going through it's moving so
fast it's going to happen
the next phase therefore is searching
for meaning of life
so there'll be more spiritual aspects
will become more mainstream
and how do you bring spirituality
surprisingly
in the business world would become the
next debate
after the digital transformation
and and i think that kind of ties in
with the
the notion of sustainability because
yeah
one of the aspects of sustainability is
um a spiritual value of
you know respecting uh nature
respecting the world we live in so
that's a kind of a foreshadowing um
we have time for i think the last
question which kind of also merges a few
questions there's a number of people
rahul here for example asks i'm an mba
in marketing
and an engineering grad and
i'm frustrated because i i'm limited to
sales roles in the it
industry um what would be a good way
to move in my career
to get to where i want to go would be to
step down learn some tech skills
um and position myself as a
technical technically capable manager
first of all you have an ideal
combination
engineering puts you a discipline
learning about pretty high level stuff
more calculus you know
quantitative stem whatever we call it
managing them by selling
is a good stepping stone to go some
other place
while the society does not respect
selling
it does one thing very important it's
the sales
function that will make you more modest
because
among all the people customers have the
on bad habit of saying no even though
logically they should buy your product
you'll learn it's very tough job in many
ways
so i always have said that before you
become a manager in a company
managing people you really need to be
sent out
after your engineering and mba for two
years of
hardcore selling even if it's a lifting
soap boxes you know like toilet soap and
uh hindustan liver kinds of companies or
repro company
consumer care out there dealing with the
traders
etc it will make you humble it will make
you very humble
because here is a trader who may not be
as educated as you are
but he will try to outsmart you or he'll
be most resistant to change so you will
learn
how to overcome resistance to change or
assistance to buy
then you come inside the company and
become a manager
now you understand why people object to
what you wanted
them to do i've always recommended that
so but
selling itself unless you have the
aptitude of
becoming a professional salesperson many
people love it
then it's fine but otherwise you migrate
out of that function
using that experience into marketing
area
or non-marketing area in the marketing
area for example you can easily go
on the brand management side which is
less about selling
more about understanding customers etc
you can go
from marketing alone to just staying on
the digital marketing front
which is a very interesting area or you
can go from marketing to an r
d function surprisingly because you have
an engineering degree
people will allow you to go into the r d
function where you bring the customer
perspective
which typically engineers don't have so
i can show you a number of paths you can
do
and ultimately by the way if nothing
works
best thing is to become an entrepreneur
good education
good learning about how to work in a
large corporation
all the politics that are involved in
large corporations
the bureaucracy now you can become a
good entrepreneur yourself
and say what can i be an
entrepreneurship is not
silicon valley you can be an
entrepreneur in anything
so it's very important you can be an
entrepreneur in starting a
coffee shop you can be an entrepreneur
in starting a
ice cream shop you can do
entrepreneurship and during the kobe
lockdown
you know how many people became
innovators
improvisation they learned so much quite
a few are spinning out as a businesses
giving up their typical uh you know
education based career they're saying
enough is enough now i can do something
else that i really am enjoying it came
out of sheer
circumstances or by accident in many
ways so maybe that's another option that
you may have
to say let me think about becoming
self-employed
or being an excellent advice
i'm going to go ahead
and close off this part of the
presentation with the final poll
window up for people
and you have about a half a minute uh
two-part
question first what skills are you
interested in learning
along your lifelong learning path and
when do you plan to start
um there's an expression that's uh you
know the
humorous expression is when is today the
best time to start got about 15 seconds
four three two
one and i'll share with you the poll
results
not surprisingly because of our topic
business and
project management is the most popular
response
but a lot of people are interested in
fields of data science ai
product or digital marketing and
it's nice to see that a lot of people
are
agree with the idea that today is the
best time so
um with that i want to
thank you professor chef for being here
i've put up your linkedin information
for people who might want to contact you
or find out more about you
and this has been a very
wonderful session really appreciate it
thank you so much thank you for hosting
me
you're certainly welcome it's been my
pleasure um i would like to mention
i think i've put into our chat box a few
times
um our skill up program
at simply learn allows free access
to over 600 skills and counting
this is the self self-study
version with over a thousand hours of
video content available
in many different skills you a new
feature is you will receive a completion
certificate
at the end of the course and
this gives you an idea a little basic
understanding of what our
more comprehensive education products
are
so you can see this here and i will
again put in the chat box
uh in a moment the link to this and the
link to
one of our other programs on digital
transformation
and a link to our next webinar
which is thursday a little more than a
week from
today this is a live master class in how
to sharpen your interview skills
as you move up in your career um
premvos is a entrepreneur
um and a noted expert
in interviewing and
career coaching so this will be a great
session and as i said i'll put the link
into the chat box and that basically
oops concludes our our webinar
you can connect with simplylearn on our
facebook our twitter and our linkedin
channels at simply learn
or search for simply learn is the
easiest way to do that
and what i will do is right now put in
the
information in the chat box that i
mentioned but at this time
once i've done that we will be done with
the webinar and you'll be able to
log off so we want to thank everybody
for being here
um we really appreciate your taking
you all taking the time to come to our
webinar series
and we hope that this has been helpful i
apologize
to anyone whose question we were not
able to get to
because of limitations of time
um sorry for the long url for this uh
next webinar but i will also
put in
information about our other programs
and again that concludes the webinar
we thank you all for being here we thank
professor chef again
for a wonderful presentation and
we'll see you future simply learn
webinars
bye now bye
oh
you